we begin today with efforts by a rising
number of states to reopen this week
despite the risk people will get sick
from the corona virus in California tens
of thousands of people crowded the
beaches over the weekend it was tough to
see even though a stay at home order is
still in place in that state in Georgia
some businesses are now open to
customers after a controversial decision
by the state's governor there there are
signs that social distancing is helping
flatten the curve but the numbers from
the virus continue to rise we are now
nearing a million reported cases
nationwide at more than nine hundred and
sixty-five thousand and the reported
death toll is now more than 54 thousand
mark Strassmann is in Atlanta where more
businesses are expected to reopen today
mark the question on everyone's mind how
is it going so far good morning Tony
well today is gonna be interesting
this reopening this next step in
Georgia's reopening will gauge public
attitudes about all this movie theaters
and restaurants like the Waffle House
behind me can now seat people inside
they have to maintain social distancing
and it's hardly business as usual the
weekend was a little slow jason griggers
held what he called a soft opening at
his Atlanta area salon this weekend he
served a handful of clients his first
and we're trying to stagger our clients
and not just load them in here so
there's not so many people in here at
one time we can practice good social
distancing George is not alone in
relaxing stay at home orders elected
officials are making similar decisions
around the country sometimes against the
advice of public health officials social
distancing will be with us through the
summer to really ensure that we protect
one another as we move through these
phases but with roughly one in six
Americans without a job the prolonged
quarantine has shredded state economies
some governors say it's time to move
forward we're always gonna be
data-driven Oklahoma's Republican
governor Kevin Steen announced some
businesses like gyms and restaurants
will be free to open on Friday the two
guiding principles that I told
Oklahomans we're going to use to through
this whole process was the health and
safety of Oklahoma's No
and then mitigate the loss to our
economy and get our workers back working
as quickly as possible that sentiment
has bipartisan support
Colorado's Democratic governor jared
Polis announced his state's stay at home
order would end today what we know is
that what matters a lot more than the
date that the stay at home ends is what
we do going forward
it doesn't accomplish anything if it's
not replaced with practices that are
sustainable for the weeks and months
that it's likely to remain with us at
least 12 states are easing restrictions
on non-essential businesses like
restaurants salons and some retailers
none has met the CDC's guidelines for
relaxing social distancing rules a
14-day decline in hospitalizations on
Sunday near Governor Andrew Cuomo said
some businesses in his state could
reopen as soon as May 15th
he called on them to think outside the
box this is not a one-sided equation
here businesses you develop a plan on
how you would reopen given everything we
now know hundreds of businesses here
that could reopen are staying shut their
owners think it's just too soon and the
number of mayor's in Georgia agree with
that decision to stay closed they're
worried that reopening could lead to a
second wave of infections anthony mark
thank you